how you doing people i'm dave rubin it's
the reuben report direct message on
december 9th 2021 we are streaming live
on rumble on youtube and on blaze tv
subscribe to our rumble channel if you
do nothing else click the button get our
videos it's just that simple i am in a
good mood today we are doing a live q a
we got a couple dozen questions from our
friends over at
reubenreport.locals.com i've been
hinting that there's some big news
coming i believe we will announce a
little something on monday
and we got a whole bunch of questions
and my team's feeling good today and we
had a lot of comments yesterday a lot of
comments saying it was our best show
ever yesterday just the right blend of
information
humor
cheekiness
it was all there it was all there so i
feel
i feel pretty good i feel pretty pretty
pretty good so we're going to get to the
q a but i want to start off with some
good news related to covid because you
know i like to frame things in a
positive way for you biden's vaccine
mandates are crumbling you guys know
earlier in the week a federal judge
blocked his vaccine mandate for federal
workers and then yesterday
the senate voted 52-48
52-48 to stop the mandates once again
we've got some info here from reuters
the democratic-controlled u.s senate on
wednesday approved a republican measure
that would overturn president joe
biden's covet 19 vaccine or test mandate
for private businesses with two
democrats joining republicans to back
the initiative the 52-48 vote sends the
legislation to the democrat led house of
representatives where it faces strong
headwinds while biden has threatened to
veto it the legislation would overturn
administration rules ordering businesses
with a hundred or more workers to
require vaccinations or coronavirus
testing for millions of employees the
measure was not subject to senate rules
that would require 60 of its 100 members
to agree on most legislation meaning it
could pass with just a simple 51 vote
simple majority two senate democrats joe
manchin of west virginia and john tester
of montana joined 50 republicans in
voting for the bill so this is really
good sign you know one of the things
that i talked about yesterday is that
we're seeing the system kind of work
right now i know the system seems broken
i know it seems calcified nothing really
operates as it should the media so
dishonestly frames things that it's hard
to figure out what's going on at times
but we have three branches of government
right civics 101. did you take social
studies in seventh grade they might have
taught you about that we have the
executive branch that's the president
he's supposed to sign thing into laws we
have the legislative branch that's the
congress and the senate they write the
laws and then we have the judicial
branch they make sure that the laws are
legal and these things have checks and
balances to all make sure that the
system's working that no one person or
one entity or one group gets too much
power it's all kind of a beautiful
system that's worked really well for 250
years which is of course why uh so many
people on the left want to burn it down
these days well now we're seeing when
the president just says hey i've got a
pen and paper or whoever's pulling his
puppet string so behind him and they get
his arm going and gold and joe signs the
thing and he doesn't know what he saw
just signed it i don't know what i'm
signing which he does say sometimes when
he's signing things um well now the
system itself is pushing back the system
the legislative branch is saying no no
no no you can't do that the judicial
brand is saying no no no no you can't do
that and that is quite beautiful just a
bit more on what happened a couple days
ago with the federal judge and this is
from the hill a federal judge in georgia
on tuesday temporarily halted the biden
administration's covet-19 vaccine
mandate for federal contractors across
the country the ruling by u.s district
judge r stan baker an appointee of
former president trump is the latest in
a series of legal setbacks for president
biden the court acknowledges the tragic
toll that the covet-19 pandemic has
wrought throughout the nation and the
globe baker wrote in a 28-page ruling
however even in times of crisis this
court must preserve the rule of law and
ensure that the branches of government
act within the bounds of their
constitutionally granted authorities
hallelujah baker whose order blocks the
mandate while the case plays out in
court said the challengers were likely
to prevail on their claim that biden
exceeded his authority with the public
health measure federal contractors were
facing a january 18th deadline to be
fully vaccinated so this is good news
folks and not only is it good news it
shows that we the people
a government for the people by the
people that we the people are still the
ones that have power right because this
is a judge who's acting as an individual
saying what are the laws we are to be
governed by
i will make the appropriate the correct
decision in this case the senators the
two senators specifically who joined
with the republicans who said no the
president does not have the authority to
do this they acted as individuals to
make sure that they could help us that
is what we the people is all about every
time someone says i will not comply
with a edict that is unconstitutional or
that forces me to do something against
my conscience that is when we win that's
what we the people means we the people
starts with us they're not above us they
want to believe they're above us but
they're below us they work for us and
most of them should be sent out to
pasture so this is a good sign a really
good sign i hope you're feeling good
about it i know i'm feeling good about
it and once again i want to say to you
guys in this room i will never
force you to be injected with anything
against your conscience that's just the
type of man i am uh oh by the way
somebody said something really funny i
was looking at the comments yesterday
someone made a point about uh so i
mentioned that michael here bought a
tesla okay yeah we pay all right over
here at the reuben report and the guy
works hard he's allowed to do with his
money what he wants
and somebody made a point that aoc who
also has a tesla has been railing
against student debt and complaining
that she still has 17 000 worth of
student debt she makes 175 thousand
dollars a year and she wants the
government to wipe out her student debt
so when you look at those two things a
guy here who busts his ass works hard
puts his money towards something he
wants not complaining about anything no
student debt and he has no student debt
because he busts his ass and he's a good
man versus this entitled
leftist loon who makes 175 grand to tell
you how awful the system is who wants
you to pay for her college education
where she did not learn that much i
thought that was a beautiful thing and
now let's do a little q a uh charlie
says as 2021 comes to a close what
what
as 2021 comes to a close what have been
some personal and professional
highlights for you you know this was
obviously a weird year for everybody
it's particularly strange i think for me
at some level because look the show is
cooking
you know the things that i'm doing
professionally going on tv shows
right in this next book
my team is growing like all the things
that we're doing here we had you know we
just went through with our uh our
youtube guy yesterday shout out to chris
like going through our numbers like all
our numbers are the best they've been
like
all of this the work stuff the stuff
that i care about and think about
um it's all working and i think i've
really obviously come a long way in my
political evolution i speak to you as
freely as i possibly can and as openly
and with as much candor as i possibly
can i think that's why you guys watch
this show that's why you tell people
about the show that's why on the rare
occasion that i leave this house uh
people come up to me and say nice things
because you know the trolls in real life
they don't even exist they hide from you
and they never leave their basements um
so it was a really rewarding year that
you know that's that's actually kind of
cool i don't know how many people on
earth
can understand what that feeling is like
to be someone that like shares my
thoughts that's what i do right i share
my thoughts
for a living and that's that resonates
with people and say you know you've
helped me stay sane in this
um and i think about it a lot it's like
man there were a lot of people a couple
years ago
that
that i really respected that i thought
were really making sense of the world
and i watched a lot of people go off the
deep end and everyone's got their own
selective pressures and their family
things and
work things and financial pressures and
just the general state of lunacy and
trying to make sense of the madness
but i think if nothing else like the
things that i have said about covid in
the last two years are pretty freaking
consistent i think i've not lost my mind
doesn't mean that i'm right about
everything but like i just tell you what
i think and then i see where we're at so
i would say on a work
uh and from a work perspective things
have been really good um and i know
that's that's very precious you know i
know a lot of people have struggled
mightily throughout all of this and uh
one of the things we've been discussing
is what we can do in the reuben report
community to help people a little bit
more and figure out ways to make sure
people have jobs and and all that stuff
i would say on a personal note um you
know i don't want to get too ahead of
myself right now but uh you know i've
been hinting for quite some time that
david and i are working on expanding the
family um so there's some some good
stuff cooking on that front and um
life's good in that way like we've got
good friends and
life is life is good life is good and i
think if you build something good and
you keep your eye on the prize like good
things can happen that's really what i
believe thanks for asking uh aaron says
who got the best who's got the best
chance in 2024 in your opinion well look
biden obviously will not be running i
don't think he's going to make it to the
four years let's keep in mind the guy
hasn't even been president for a year
and look at the
just systemic i would say in the right
use of systemic just the breakdown of
his cognitive faculties
he was at bob dole's funeral today a
video went out and he's reading his
speech and you know he reads end of line
or turn page it's like
that thing ain't good
his approval rating is terrible kamala's
is even worse i think the republicans
have a really interesting crop of people
of course that puts desantis at the top
but i think there's guys like tim scott
i think there's nikki haley i think
there's dan crenshaw i think there's a
whole bunch of people and i get it maybe
you don't like this person you don't
like that person this guy did this and
she said that and all those things of
course there's the orange man like all
of these things are in play
to me the best thing for the country as
i've said many times would be that ron
desantis becomes the standard bearer of
the republican party of the conservative
movement
he knows how to fight he believes in
individual choice and freedom he is
balanced
keeping the people of florida safe along
with individual responsibility he kept
the state open florida is freaking
flourishing
while so much of the country is not
he's younger i think he's 43.
i mentioned about a month ago i was at a
dinner with him actually sat next to him
had some one-on-one time but also within
a group atmosphere he knows his stuff he
struck me as a decent honest guy like
you know he gave a talk before that for
i don't know about 200 people all off
the top of his head for about an hour
answered as many questions as he
possibly could i think there's a
generational thing we have to get rid of
not get rid of we have to sort of let
some of the older politicians just get
out of the way the world is very
different nancy pelosi does not fully
get the world younger people the gen x
people that are supposed to be in the
prime of our lives right now say say
between 36 something like that 36 and
you know late 50s like while you're
still your body is still working and
your mind is still sharp and you
understand the way the world's changing
you remember the old world but you also
remember how the internet came in and
all of the stuff it's like we should be
doing it right now so i so i think he
should be the guy and what i would want
of donald trump is to be the bodyguard
man put the ego aside if you can and i
know that will be tough
and be the guy that's in the media every
day
railing against the nonsense that
they're going to throw at desantis do
the rallies and it just doesn't have to
be that every rally has a giant trump
flag it could just say freedom or
america or maga or whatever but that
that all of us it's everyone versus the
woke right now and we can then hash out
all the other differences i'm a little
more libertarian than say a traditional
christian conservative but hey we all
want to live in roughly the same country
let's figure it out man so i think
desantis is the way to go which by the
way you know a lot of people in florida
probably don't want that because they
want that guy to stay there for as long
as possible and keep that state strong
um
but there are other people in florida
you know you got francis suarez who's
the incredible mayor of miami maybe he
could be governor i mean there's all
sorts of interesting things that could
play out amy says if you could go back
in time and give young dave a piece of
advice what would it be and why ooh i
like that we're mixing these up from
straight up politics today um
[Music]
you know it's funny i don't have a lot
of regrets
i would say it's a little bit like frank
sinatra my way of regret
i've got a few
but then again
too few to mention
that wasn't a great sinatra that was
that was all right but i the the song my
way actually does kind of sum up how i
view the world like you do the best you
can and you can't really have made you
know if you have major regrets then
things really went terrible but
that doesn't mean that i did everything
right like i was very hard on myself in
my 20s uh related to my sexuality and i
regret that i regret beating myself up
um i regret some of my behavior at that
time like like that sort of thing like
and and those scars
they don't just disappear like they can
live with you for a long time um so i
guess being a little bit easier on
myself but beyond that
you know sure little things that i wish
maybe i'd done this differently or that
differently but like i think in the big
sense of things like as the world
changed and as media changed all that i
made the right decisions along the way i
said i want to be independent i want to
build my own business i want to you know
i want to start fighting things and not
just talking about things and that's how
locals appeared and like all of those
things so i think i sort of roughly did
that right so i'll answer i guess the
the best piece of advice
that i would give a younger self would
be trust yourself like trust your
instincts i think that's really it
probably like i think you have to trust
your gut a wise man once told me my
buddy john once told me you know you got
to trust your gut until it goes so
horrifically awry that then you
re-evaluate but you know you
intrinsically know stuff about yourself
and about the world and if you do really
what you think is right for the right
reasons then i don't think that'll lead
you too far off the path and if it does
lead you off the path then path then you
can think about it right but i think i
think that would be so if anything the
advice would be hey
be a little easier on yourself and trust
yourself and see what happens
uh philip says does any of the quote
unquote big news you have been referring
to involved clyde getting his own show
clyde would like a show man this dog you
know we had emma before clyde some of
you remember emma and emma was a rescue
from hurricane katrina new orleans gave
birth during the hurricane they found
her in a box during the hurricane with
the puppies she was very sick for a long
time lived a wonderful life till about
16 years
we had to say goodbye to her right
before lockdown we weren't going to get
another dog for a while but then i i saw
this um
tv report like a day before all the full
lockdowns were hitting in la and it was
like they're going to put down all these
dogs and i just ran there
and i just grabbed him and and we saved
him he's he's living the good life right
now he's a little nuts you know he's
part pit part boxer and boxers have
incredible crazy energy and clyde i
think i mentioned this once before but
i'll mention again clyde so he jumps up
we're working on getting him
uh trained a little bit better because
when people visit us and we have a lot
of dinner parties he always jumps on
everybody and we're trying to get him to
calm down but one time
we had
bob saget over and his lovely wife kelly
and bob opened the door and i said bob
you know watch out because clyde does
have a way of punching people in the
nuts and bob kind of laughed at me next
they know clyde jumps on him boxers
they're called boxers because they box
because when they jump they just start
punching clyde punched bob saget right
in the nuts down goes danny tanner
after a little tequila everything was
fine
uh eileen says i wish we could have a
different health expert for the country
instead of fouchy any ideas whom you
would want that's a great question so
first off obviously it should not be
pharma it should be someone that perhaps
didn't sell out to big pharma someone
that's not incentivized to fund you know
his colleagues research product uh
projects and has done so many things
wrong i mean look at fauci and some of
the aids stuff in the 80s someone who
wouldn't have the gall
the gall and the ego to basically say i
am the science if you challenge me you
challenge the very nature of science as
if he's palpatine i am the senate um and
of course i would also want someone who
values american values right like
personal liberty individual choice
freedom
your capacity to run your life as you
see fit so now who that person would be
i don't know i don't know that there's
anyone in the sort of
mainstream science community
right now i guess what you would want
is someone that was a better
communicator maybe not even with the
full scientific set of knowledge that
fauci has because it's about
communicating this stuff that's why i'm
always interested in the media side of
things because it's how we get
communicated and what we hear through
the filter that is that important so if
you had incred if you had really
incredible non-corrupt scientists
working on vaccines trying to tell us
where the the virus came from all of
that stuff and then you had a head of
that department not to say he was
completely you know knew nothing about
science
whatsoever but like someone who could
just communicate those ideas who knew
how to speak to the camera who knew how
to honestly answer questions who knew
how to say i don't know when i don't
know or who knew not who knew how not to
always kick the can down the road or not
to give the vague answers that fouchy
always gives about when things get to a
tolerable level and it's like two years
later did we ever get there did we
flatten the curve blah blah blah um
so you know i i actually don't know who
that is there's probably some good
people that can do that i would love to
hear your thoughts on that because i'd
gladly have them on the show
ben says i got my book plate 902 out of
5 000. that's right i signed 5 000 book
plates which we only put up for the
locals community for the numbered book
plates for don't burn this country
we will be doing some signed stuff that
will not be numbered as we get closer to
release in april uh now on to my
question why does corporate media almost
never fire analysts like tubin
on the contrary why do you think they
can cuomo that's a good question too so
first off why don't they fire people
like tuban
um i think it partly
is because it's all a protection racket
right like you get these jobs these are
you get paid a ton of money you become
famous you have influence you're an
insider with all the politicians
everyone's sort of bullshitting together
right so like if you're on cnn and you
always and you take like the main cnn
people it's like you take tapper and you
take blitzer and you take wolf it's i
mean it sounds like a demented reindeer
group but if you take uh you take cuomo
and you take don lemon and whatever you
take all of these people it's like
they're all democrats right we all know
that they're they're liberals or lefties
or democrats and they all have to play a
game together that is probably a
somewhat unspoken game of oh we are
journalists we're not activists and then
we have to kind of protect each other
within that because if we don't then
somebody could really drop the boom and
you know expose all of us so i would
guess a guy like tuban it's like
it's up for anyone i don't watch cnn you
know i know a little bit of tuban
fortunately i've never zoomed with the
guy but you know um i would suspect that
he's probably a perfectly fine
broadcaster let's say let's say he's a
decent legal analyst um i know that he
was a student actually of alan
dershowitz and now he he's always
attacking alan dershowitz alan
dershowitz who by the way alan
dershowitz usually has a pretty freaking
good track record on what's going on
legally in this country
but that aside let's say he's a decent
analyst uh jeffrey tubin well you can't
fire him because he's kind of in on it
as i just said
and uh why did they fire cuomo i think
that the cuomo stuff was just too
obvious like there's a lot of ways they
can push things under the rug there's a
lot of stories they can ignore for
example right now cnn i don't watch cnn
so please correct me if i'm wrong but
there are protests all over the world
anti-vaccine mandate protests they're
happening in austria they're happening
in new zealand in australia they're
happening in the uk they're happening in
france they're happening all over south
america all over the world have they
been on uh cnn once has any video of
that made it to cnn now that is a type
of a conspiracy they have said we are
not going to show people here in america
that other people are standing up
because because they don't want people
here to realize that they can stand up
and you can stand up right um so i think
what happened with cuomo was it was so
egregious whatever it is that will be
one day fully exposed that he did
whether it was coordination with his
brother whether it was suppressing
stories whatever all of that stuff is it
was too obvious there obviously is a
paper trail on it probably i would guess
him well we know some of this already
that we know he was emailing producers
and how they were going to cover things
and the irony of course
is anyone with half a brain that had
watched any of that coverage with him
and his brother the entire time would
know that this was all nonsense and
theater and when he pretended he had
coveted and came up from the basement
and said he had been quarantining for
days and then you know the next day it
turned out that he he had been found a
week earlier
fighting with a biker in the hamptons
it's like man you guys just lie about
everything so i think that one just got
to critical mass and they had to do it
as for tuban i'll just say one other
thing which is it's like first off
like don't masturbate on a work call
like just as a general rule okay guys i
think i've made that clear before um
that's just like a rule that you
shouldn't do um but why did they bring
it back it is a little odd and it has to
do something with that inner circle
thing because otherwise it's like why
wouldn't you just fire him and and hire
somebody else like it would just be like
the easy thing to do like ah jeffrey
nobody's perfect but you jacked off on a
on a zoom call we've got to hire
somebody else and then do what you
always are preaching it's like then do a
diversity hire find me a black lesbian
trans
whatever and bring them in because
there's got to be a black lesbian trans
whatever legal analyst and they deserve
a job
kathy says uh do you think the tide is
turning against mandates at least in
america it seems there have been some
significant court wins already well
obviously i touched on this at the top
of the show i do think so
i think it's important that if you see
the videos that i just referred to which
you're really only seeing on twitter
right now these videos of mass protests
and not only just mass protests really
awful things happening in some places
you know in germany you've got you've
got policemen literally grabbing old
women off the street because they don't
have their vax papers like really
terrible stuff and as i've asked several
times this week what will you do
what will you do if the [ __ ] was really
hitting the fan what will you do in a
time when bad things are happening
i asked myself that question i think we
all should ask ourselves that question
but to
to your point there are some big wins in
america right now
do not underestimate that the senate did
something good
not because they passed the law because
they stopped the ever encroachment of
government the senate just did that
pretty good the federal court
just did that that's pretty good so
we're getting some wins and every win
every win is is something that that can
boost you not a coveted booster but
something that can make you go oh
there's hope there are others there's
something in the distance that we can
get to that's what i want to focus on
and that's what we're going to keep
talking about
brad says what are your thoughts on the
fda now saying 50 years isn't enough
time to release the pfizerkovitvax trial
data now it's 75 years so if you don't
know about this this is really bananas
stuff
pfizer is in essence saying that for 50
years they're going to hold all the
records related to what happened in the
trials of the covid vaccines i mean this
is really crazy and now there's this it
might be 75 years and who knows what
will happen then i mean it's crazy it's
absolutely crazy we seem to be governed
at this point by you know boards of
pharmaceutical companies that's a
problem we played the video a couple
weeks ago where the 17 member i believe
it was the fis no it was the fda panel
17 members where they're debating
whether they should give shots to kids
that are five to eleven kids who by the
way have something like a ninety nine
point nine nine nine nine percent chance
of surviving code in the first place
whether they should all have uh you know
get vaccinated and literally the doctor
says we don't know what the side effects
are we'll have to find out after we
start doing injections
and it's like we all just sit there and
we go oh
well
a random guy said it who he sits on a
board of a pharmaceutical company he
must be in it for the good reasons he
must really care about us i think so
much of this stuff is getting exposed
day by day that the more hysterical they
get the more crazy they get this
nonsense with omicron which right now
we're hearing is mostly uh the least
the least intense of all of the variants
right you'll get mild sickness and
either way even if you've got
moderate sickness or moderate to heavy
sickness sorry guys you don't control
our lives anymore you don't deserve our
attention or our respect anymore so
that's really where we need to focus
that these pharmaceutical companies are
in on it with media they're in on it
with the politicians like this is not
conspiracy stuff this is basic stuff
remember that video that we showed you a
couple weeks ago where all the the
daytime talk shows
and so much of cable news is brought to
you brought to you by pfizer
like that's a problem that is is there a
way we can pull that video up mid show
we can't do that right now all right
we'll we'll play that in the next day or
so
but that's a problem when the the
pharmaceutical companies are sponsors on
cnn and then cnn brings on
pharmaceutical company people to tell
you what to inject your kid with and you
go okay
i'd like more
peter says
did you receive any threat letters with
cut out newsport newspaper letters about
your cat remarks yesterday it's a crazy
world after all okay i'm glad you
brought this up look i mentioned
yesterday that i don't like cats i just
don't like cats and i believe in
individual choice now i also mentioned
yesterday that cats are libertarian and
a lot of people said well dave how could
you not like cats if cats are
libertarian because you're so
libertarian-minded because cats they
don't like rules
they're kind of solo they just exist as
the world is right i like dogs i like
you know the idea that a dog is you come
home a dog jumps on you maybe punches
you in the nuts a dog licks you a dog
cuddles up with you
i like attention i like the the warmth
of a dog cats aren't thought to be warm
cats are always trying to kill people i
mean there's you know all the videos of
on youtube cat you know jumps on a knife
stabs grandma in the eye you know
there's there's a lot with the cats
right like now i get it some people like
cats oh and by the way i'm not saying
that every single cat is bad you
watching this right now i'm sure you
have the best cat ever and they're just
fantastic and i will say there's one cat
that i've met that i like
okay candace owens has a cat her cat's
name is bear so bear is not a bear bear
is a cat but bear acts like a dog so
it's a cat named bear who acts like a
dog and this dog this cat will come up
to you and it'll cuddle with you and now
i'm allergic to cats so bear has
approached me several times and tries to
you know get up on my leg and do bear's
thing i'll let her
actually i'm not even sure if it's a him
or her come to think of it but i'll let
the he her or whatever they so choose as
their gender pronouns to do what they
want for a little bit but then i have i
have a limit uh but anyway i i don't
want to uh besmirch the entire cat
community i understand some people like
[ __ ] it's just not for me all right
margot
margot
yeah uh margaret wrap it up dave
margot says do you think that by
continually bringing attention to the
ones who are deliberately
misrepresenting facts i.e the mainstream
media we inadvertently give them more
attention than they deserve or is it
because the majority of the population
is being misled our repetition is in
hopes that people will finally hear our
alarm clock i wonder what clyde thinks
about all this people do love clyde um
this is a great question you know i
address this often on the show and i
this is if there was one thing that i
would say i
it's not quite struggle with for the
show but i really grapple with like the
direction of the show when i look at the
stories in the morning and when michael
and i are deciding what to cover it's
like every single day i could just do a
show where we show you clips
of genuinely insane people on msnbc or
we could just show you clips of people
that i think once were sane on the view
like joy behar and whoopi goldberg who
have become shrieking harpies who are
nuts who say crazy crazy things and
we could do that like we could do that
and by the way this goes for cnn or i
could take every new york times headline
like we could do that and just cover all
of that all the time and it's like
there's reason to do it right you're
addressing that in your question there's
reason to do it because these people do
have audiences right like there's a lot
the view i think is like the number one
daytime talk show now i don't know how
many maybe we can get some numbers on
the view like people watch the view
and let's say let's say a broad swath
of housewives in america are watching
this and let's say they're not online
and they're not seeing what really is
true and they're hearing about this
endless hysteria and everything else
it's like that's kind of dangerous and
then their hus you know the husband
comes home and now the wife's been
watching the view all day and watching
msnbc and hearing endlessly about terror
and fear and how horrible things are and
everything else and everyone's dying and
the husband comes home and let's say the
husband is maybe apolitical or maybe
watched the reuben report or something
else now you live in a different world
and we know that people are having all
sorts of problems with relationships and
family members and everything else i'm
sure you guys have some version of that
for yourself uh an average of 2.3
million people watch the view every day
like that's a chunk of people and most
of those people are insane so what do we
do about it like
so that so i do i grapple with that
because on one hand i want to expose the
nonsense on the other hand it's like
msnbc's ratings suck cnn's ratings suck
i often point out that our clips
often get way more views with a team you
know just a couple people in here with
me just saying what i think off the top
of my head our clips often do way way
better than anything on cnn on any given
day so on one hand it's like ah just
ignore them and they'll go away on the
other hand you want to expose it so that
hopefully the people that are in the
middle kind of bouncing back and forth
not really sure what is what that they
might come a little bit more in our
direction but i don't know i love
hearing your thoughts on this because i
don't know exactly what the right thing
is to do and and you know on another
just like on a personal note like it's
when i show you these joy read clips
like they're so ridiculous that it's
like fun for me and then i can make fun
of her and whatever but on the other
hand like i'd much rather i really do
mean this like i would much rather live
in a sane
relatively like not bananas society and
have less videos that we have to do like
if every morning i woke up and i was
like boy there's not much going on right
now the government seems to be kind of
slim and trim and people aren't crazy
and we got rid of the crazy woke lefties
and everything's kind of humming along
and boy we're only going to do a six
minute show today
all right like i'll find some other
things to do you know i really will
we'll get you guys got hobbies what do
you do
you ever do any
you know hobbies what do you do
what ps we will play more ps4 okay if uh
if the world cleans itself up jeff says
where do you see kaylee mcinanny in the
future big plans so i interviewed kaylee
we put up uh parts one and two are on
youtube right now the full is up at
rubyreport.locals.com she of course was
the uh previous press secretary before
the wizard known as jen saki she was
donald trump's press secretary really
did a bang-up job like and she's just a
good person we've become friendly i know
her a bit off camera as well just a nice
a nice decent human being she's one of
the co-hosts on outnumbered on fox now
um
i asked her a little bit about her
future plans if you watch the full
interview um i don't know she was an
extremely effective communicator going
back to the earlier question about who
would you want to run nih or cdc or
fda like any of these organizations that
have to communicate information to us
it's like she was the type of person
that i would want doing that it doesn't
mean that kaylee herself is like the
perfect scientist for the job but it's
like if you have the right scientists
and you hire the right people then you
need a communicator to get those things
across so i suspect i mean could i see a
situation where you know desantis
becomes president or dare i say even
orange man does again and she jumps back
into the fray like it was very obvious
to me she enjoyed it she enjoyed
fighting the media she enjoyed trying to
get as much truth across as possible so
uh i think it's all possible uh angel
says would you ever do tim poole's tim
cast irl i think it would be pretty
awesome yeah i absolutely would you know
i think he tapes now out of west
virginia if i'm not mistaken i think
that's where he is uh he asked me to do
it very early on you know i don't get to
west virginia that often he doesn't do
stuff uh via skype or
zoom or over the pipes let's say um so i
think one day when one of my travels
maybe gets me to dc and i'm a little bit
closer i get to maryland or whatever it
might be but i'd be happy to do it by
the way i know that uh tim was a bit
critical of uh the rumble deal the deal
we did with locals and and everything
that subsequently happened i think he
got a bunch of things factually wrong i
liked him um dan bongino put up a video
that that countered a bunch of the stuff
that i think tim just didn't have a full
set of information when he was talking
about some stuff i'm not doing this to
get into a flame war or anything like
we're roughly on the same side of things
but i would be more than happy to do it
like if if he wants to bring me on to do
a two-hour show just discussing what's
going on with locals and rumble and how
to build separate rails and why i think
this was the right deal i'm more than
happy to do it and i have no doubt that
you twitter people will now clip this
and tell him so that's just fine suzanne
says what is your favorite holiday movie
you know i got this one a couple days
ago my go-to is always christmas
vacation i just think it's perfect it's
like peak chevy chase it's just great
and fun and wonderful i do count die
hard as a christmas movie uh we always
do christmas story uh at least once on
christmas day often like two or three
times you know on tnt i don't have cable
anymore but for the years of my life
that i had cable before we cut the cord
tnt would show 24 hours of christmas
story over and over and over and over so
we would just be kind of watching
throughout the day
um i would say those are probably the
big three on the on the holiday side of
things yeah that that would probably be
it uh guys in closing reminder part two
of my interview with kaylee who we just
talked about is up on youtube right now
full things up ad free report.locals.com
tomorrow we've got a friday round table
extravaganza with matt ridley elijah
schaefer and jake paquette and then on
monday
we we've got some big news
i'm pretty sure it's going to be on
monday there's a small chance it could
be on tuesday
we're pushing for monday
and i feel good
i
sense that you feel good about how i
feel good these guys feel good there's
goodness out there
and
it's a lovely time of year i think good
things are happening
nice chatting with you have a good day
see you tomorrow